[Music]
what if you took your school assignment
to the next level and decided to collect
physical samples of as many elements as
possible how far it into the periodic
table could you get would you be
breaking any laws at what point would
your periodic table start killing you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you collected all the elements
on the periodic table if you're willing
to spend about $1,700 you could actually
buy a ready-made set of the elements
online but where's the fun in that if
you can make your own collection from
scratch scrape off the layer of copper
on a penny minted after 1982 and you'll
get pure zinc teardown smoke detectors
for americium in the end you could even
pull some pure gold from your old cell
phone no matter how you collect your
elements you should always keep them in
their sealed bottles but what if you
didn't what if out of curiosity you
decided to put all 118 elements together
to resemble the actual table without any
glass barriers there are seven rows in
the periodic table starting in the first
row hydrogen and helium wouldn't cause
you any trouble aside from them rising
upward and dispersing right away these
elements are just like your introvert
friend who always leaves the party
before it gets good next the second row
if you weren't careful enough you'd
start coughing and have difficulty
breathing
that's what beryllium poisoning looks
like at this point you should consider
wearing a gas mask because you'd also
have yellow fluorine gas spreading on
the floor and burning everything it
touches other elements of the second row
are harmless neon would simply float
away while oxygen and nitrogen would
drift around until they disperse you
wouldn't stop at just two rows would you
know so let's move to the third one it
would burn you with fire
sulfur normally doesn't do anything bad
other than stink but with fluorine and
chlorine by its side it would
immediately catch fire on top of that
white phosphorous would spontaneously
burst into hot flames that would be very
hard to extinguish maybe you want to
just stick to doing chemistry class
experiments hmm instead with your lab on
fire you decide to go on and stack the
fourth row fine
adding potassium to the mix would set
the arsenic on fire to releasing large
amounts of arsenic trioxide you sure
don't want to inhale that toxic stuff
there would be some interesting effect
so as the elements on your periodic
table were reacting to each other
aluminum would become soft as wet paper
sulfur would stop smelling so bad but if
you weren't careful exposure to toxic
smoke would have already killed you
these toxic elements would eat your body
and your mask too
but you're too smart to die so early in
the experiment you'd be watching from a
safe distance
and you'd live to stack the fifth row
this row would be much like the fourth
except for one thing say hello to the
first radioactive element in your
collection technetium you still alive
over there well the next row the table
would fix that because the sixth row
contains radon polonium promethium and
astatine all radioactive elements that
you don't want anywhere near you ever
stacking them together would result in a
massive explosion and a cloud of toxic
fire and dust in a matter of
milliseconds you'd get a lethal dose of
radiation at that point there would be
no one left to add the seventh row to
your periodic table that's probably for
the best since most of the elements are
so unstable they can't exist longer than
a few minutes they would radioactively
decay into elements that also decay
wonder what that looks like
the reactions from adding a seventh row
would be like a nuclear bomb exploding
over and over again a mushroom cloud
would rise over the area it wouldn't
just be radioactive fallout it would
leave the radioactive footprint of
thousands of Chernobyl disasters so if
you want to pick a new hobby keep in
mind there are a lot better things to
collect
[Music]
you